hier c'est ce que vous voulez qu'on joue
à un jeu à la chasse non non on va jouer
je suis très joueurs il est très joueur
on a joint je suis gagnant alors on va
faire un jeu qui s'appelle l'interview
mensonge vous bougez pas pendant le
jingle
impeccable
à redon à la c1 en j'essaye d'instituer
un rituel bon maxime gremetz alors vous
c'est un jeu qui s'appelle l'interview
mensonge vous répondez sans dire la
vérité
comme si vous étiez un homme politique
jeunesse pas faire je pose une question
et vous me répondez en montant on est
bien d'accord
est ce que vous êtes toujours ultra
libérale oui plus que jamais ça vous
plaît les formidables ultralibéralisme
regarder des millions de pause des
profits labour formidable vous avez bien
compris le jeu est ce que c'est vrai que
vous avez coucher pour réussir
oui libye connaît le doigt et je me
couche tard et bien c'est bien connu
jospin 9 le devrais je me couche à 100
mais vous faites un maximum de fric en
tant que membre du parti communiste
formidable
ouais je sais plus quoi en faire
d'ailleurs je donne beaucoup bonnes
oeuvres je vais gérer
j'ai rencontré mon ami creton rey défend
les bonnes causes jouer daudet plein
d'argent
vous avez déjà frauder le fisc oui
probablement
ils vérifient la petite finale pas prise
n'a pas fraudé le fisc et boul
si je vous pose la question on dirait
oui oui bah oui d'ailleurs que le
mensonge est ce que vous trompez
toujours votre femme tous les jours bah
oui maintenant à l'échelle de temps
c'est vrai que vous avez une invention
avec karen cheryl oui tout à fait c'est
des merveilles
il ya des boîtes échangistes aviles tête
non non non rien
merci au ralliement
bravo très bien atteint du mensonge
c'est du rhin non non c'est pas dur même
dit pas que c'est à dire avec va
apprendre à mentir ça s'apprend où ça